let's talk about this Kanye gap
situation mm-hmm
so for those who don't know Kanye has
partnered with the gap he's gonna bring
easy over to the gap I think that this
is the most genius business deal that I
have witnessed in the last decade I just
put that time line up now so I'll
probably all right I'll tell you why
gap is struggling right because the
other like super fast fashion places are
biting it there's our as the top shops
the H&M Zara eh and I'm still in
business but still like it's a cheaper
clothing but it actually has more cachet
because they're doing cooler Styles etc
and then gap kind of just became like
bland yes right you know it's just like
kind of like regular clothes like you
when we were growing up like a gray gap
sweatsuit was kind of fire I don't know
right like they had a run they had a run
rooms that can add a nice crewneck [ __ ]
where it's just a gap on the chest
remember the sweatshirt yeah they had
the original MacBook commercials with
just a white background and then a guy
talking in front of completely whites
Korea and [ __ ] was kind of fired so and
everything went downhill when they
stopped dancing in a commercial remember
when they were doing like swing and [ __ ]
in the commercial it was fire but
basically what happened is as these new
things pop up cap kind of gets lost in
the sauce because it's not as elegant as
like the sister company Banana Republic
I think Banana Republic is owned by gap
right so it's like it would go Banana
Republic gap old Navy
yeah old Navy would still occupy the
bottom rung where a lot of people just
didn't have the money you could get
clothes for pretty cheap they had that
cargo short run and Old Navy was poppin
I think we all world Navy back in a day
and a gap with this this like middle
ground was like almost like rich kids
war gap yeah you know like your parents
the rich kids parents will buy them gap
stuff and then gap kind of falls out of
favor huh but what I love about the deal
is Yeezy brings the cool factor mm-hmm
gap brings the quality if easy partners
with H&M or any of these [ __ ]
partner with H&M I think Beyonce partner
with Topshop or some like that
she brings all the equity but the
quality still trash Topshop is trash
quality yes not has a little bit it's
hardly tenant but like barely you wash
your shirt twice that [ __ ] is [ __ ]
like the threads are starting to come
out it's not good quality the thing with
gap is Yeezy is bringing his brand
equity to a brand that's quality's
already high so now I'm like I would
wear this [ __ ] if it's good I would wear
this [ __ ] yeah you could buy something
from it and it's gonna maintain its
[ __ ] value unlike these other things
we're gonna take the original gap closed
and put a couple holes in it this was he
finally dropped a conscious song today
about essentially black lives matter
oh really saying but yeah he dropped
that shoe with Travis Scott the hole and
that's that the timing of that is
perfect no I just partner with the
widest clothes on the face of the earth
yeah there you go everybody yeah look
I'm oka again we're good right black
lives matter I mean not the life of my
wife hey let me find another black guy
who married a white woman as well in the
same family yeah that does not saying
that you can't do that obviously you
can't but it is interesting because
you're saying this might be more
performative and maybe it's a marketing
video a marketing video right right
right
you can't alienate your audience too
much mark what do you thought as far as
the deal that thing is smart like gap
was gonna be out in five years you think
yeah without this gaff we've been done
five years like their [ __ ] look was like
free-falling
yeah my never getting squeezed so hard
between Old Navy and the rest their [ __ ]
would your generation where gap I mean
our Gabbar still to this day yeah of
these jeans really come on bro yeah but
you bought them in some store where
anyone else wore them and then you got
them now I got it from the gap you went
to the gap yeah that's my [ __ ] bro I
been on yet I don't know about the gap
anymore so yeah
holy storm mark gets firsthand [ __ ] from
they don't make that [ __ ] more
breathable bada cheese between your butt
ain't much of a gap brother sweaty what
did you say was it on it yeah oh it's
like so I was passing by and marks shoe
dropped and I picked it up for him and
handed it to him and it was so hot and
I'm like damn not only giant ass always
hot you feed a [ __ ] hot think five
years they out of here and then Yeezy
has prolonged that depending on the
success of it yeah and Yeezy
revolutionize adidas I think I think he
did revolutionize adidas I'm skeptical
that he's gonna do that for gap but I've
been wrong about easy before I keep
doubt in Kanye and then he keeps winning
so I think it's guaranteed to win cuz
the gaps at the bottom so the only place
you can go with you get the stock nice
and cheese a penny stock right now it's
like the [ __ ] lowest will ever be
I just depending on how much they paid
Kanye can they afford it and he might
just got paid in a ton of stock equity
or some [ __ ] like that
mm-hm you know the interesting thing
about paying Kanye is like or for this
is if the deal is only a year or two
years but you bring back the value of
the brands any amount you pay him as
worth it you know it's a 10-year deal oh
really
yeah so this is like this is Carly does
this and then maybe he's out the game
McCartney's gonna be what what does he
like fifty five tiny in ten years
yeah already something now yeah in ten
years yeah but um I don't know cuz he's
shaky when it comes to a lot of these
business stuff like lately he's been
putting out his own [ __ ] and he prides
himself in putting out his own [ __ ] with
this it's like uh is it more the gap is
it more him and I know he has control of
the easy bread hmm and this seems like
it's a partnership so I think they're
gonna let him do whatever he wants yeah
for Yeezy gap not design all the gap I
think easy gap will be like a subset of
gap just like I think easy was a subset
of adidas got it
he's not overseeing that yeah I thought
he just let this rock if I'm adidas I'm
like nah but I like you you want to
partner with us you want to do this with
us like make your brand within us now
but he only has a shoe deal with adidas
he doesn't have clothing his whole thing
is straight him you can't go to adidas
and get easy clothing selling son
I thought uses a billion-dollar company
or something it is a billion-dollar
company that's what's interesting
because I think they the heat of Yeezys
the shoes at least yeah there was a time
it was the hottest [ __ ] shoes and now
it's not there anymore but the worth has
grown so it's like maybe they maybe like
heat know necessarily mean money we all
know I think you know I know some dope
warfare brand warfare yeah let's say I'm
Nicky and I want to take out Adidas I
get some Karen's to throw some [ __ ] in a
grocery store wearing all Yeezy
to move right whoever the most hated
person is put them in the opposition
opposition's gear and now all the sudden
those new clogged [ __ ] things that
easy put out in there it's like oh those
are the Cameron sneaker the caring clogs
I mean it's diabolical but if they get
caught it's a wrap that's true you're
sort of caught it's a rat you guys do I
kill them
yeah you just pay them so much it's like
whatever we didn't do had that Long
Island white [ __ ] or whatever the dude
wearing the mag hats and the videos
talking to the phone I love her put her
in Puri this is how I dress for my
sparring races this woman is a legend
Tina for tea you love you we want you on
a pot yeah yeah yeah yeah Tom loves be
mad different now she's coming on
everything so what do you think gosh you
think it's legit enough I mean listen I
like I said I've been wrong about Kanye
every step of the way I don't I don't
think this is this a big swing to me to
make the gap cool again that [ __ ] is
like 20 years old so my gap being quite
think you worked at the gap as a kid
they ships he talks about working at the
gap yeah exactly so he worked at the gap
as a killer things even wrapped about it
yeah spaceship yeah actually the gap
yeah go back back to the gap yeah so I
think he's on some nostalgic [ __ ] too
that's dope [ __ ] you
he didn't like working there what now
how are ya ah beeps oh yeah I think so
because uh they threatened him for
stealing or some [ __ ] like that really I
mean he make his entire verse about
hating the gat nah I think about it yeah
on his first album spaceship whatever
I've been workin his grave shift don't I
wish I could buy me a check wasn't no
scratch yeah no never got caught
okay take me to the backing pad me hmm
accent me about some khakis it's a curse
[Laughter]
mark you know Jesus compared those to
you honey I got more white holes and
Jason Mraz yo you ready yeah but you
know the greatest rapper of all time is
who is it mark Baum atomically poppy
Harlow Harlow yo we're only doing white
rappers in 2012 only it's white
representative of music music hopin
[ __ ] white rappers ever in my life yo
who do you put higher Jack Harlow a post
Malone not jack Harlow was popping brain
who whipped his heart
I got options I could pass that [ __ ]
like Stockton on fire with a [ __ ]
no-look [ __ ] never did that every pass
yo that's a bounce pass no look these
[ __ ] anymore you got back here you
know
[Applause]